select the point 3 comma 0 over the line
y equals 2x there's a lot of steps
involved I'm going to show you how to
work with this so the first thing is
let's go ahead and graph the line y
equals 2x you're going rise to run 1 ok
the y-intercept is 0 rise to run 1 ok
and this is our line okay
but our point 3 0 1 2 3 is right there 3
0 so we want to do is we want to fold it
over this line reflect it over this line
to find the coordinates ok of the image
point so the way we're going to do this
is first we're going to find out the
slope of this line which we know is 2 y
equals MX plus B this is the slope but
the opposite reciprocal slope okay the
perpendicular slope is going to be
negative 1/2 so I just flipped the 2
over and made it the opposite sign so
what's going to happen when you reflect
a point over a line you want the
shortest distance to that line and you
go the same distance on the other side
so what we need to do is we need to
write an equation of a line that's going
to be perpendicular to this line y
equals 2x so we know the slope is
negative 1/2 we know goes through the
point 3 0 so let's go ahead and use our
point-slope form of the equation of a
line so this is going to be Y minus 0 ok
equals negative 1/2 times X minus 3 y
minus 0 is just Y and if we distribute
the negative 1/2 we get negative 1/2 x
plus 3 halves so that's the equation of
this line here so basically let's see it
has a slope of negative 1/2 and has a
y-intercept of 1.5 right here so you can
see that this is gonna look something
like like this right but now we want to
do is we want to find out where do these
two lines intersect where do they cross
and so what we're gonna do is we're
going to solve a system of equations
we've got y equals to x and y equals
negative 1/2 X plus 3 halves we can do a
substitution since y equals 2x let's put
that in place of Y and then what we'll
do is we'll solve for X but I'm what I'm
going to do is I'm going to clear the
fractions by multiplying everything by 2
so this is going to be 4x equals
negative x plus 3 so multiplying
everything by 2 to clear the denominator
so now if we add X to this side we get
5x equals 3 divide both sides by 5
and you can see that X is equal to 3/5
if we put it back in to either one of
these equations I'll just put it into
this one two times 3/5 is six fifths so
we can see that these two lines are
crossing at 3/5 comma six fifths right
there let's go ahead and write that down
3/5 comma six fifths but now what you
can realize is that when you're folding
this point over this line or reflecting
over the line we know it has to be
perpendicular we also know it has to be
the same distance on the other side so
what that means then is that this point
right here is the midpoint okay so what
we can do now is we can use our midpoint
formula remember a midpoint is the
average of the axis okay in the average
of the Y's so you add access together /
to add the lives together / - the point
is going to be somewhere over here I'm
just gonna put a generic location let's
just call this X Y now what we're gonna
do is we're going to take these x
coordinates x + 3 so if X plus 3 divided
by 2 so for finding the midpoint that
midpoint is going to equal 3/5 we're
also going to do the same thing for the
Y's y + 0 divided by 2 is going to give
us the y coordinate which is 6 fifths
okay so now if we solve these two
equations we can do some cross
multiplying here let's see 2 times 3 is
6 and 5 times X plus 3 is 5 X plus 15
subtract 15 that's going to give us
negative 9 and then if we divide both
sides by 5 we get x equals negative 9
fifths over here if we let's see y plus
0 is just y if we multiply both sides by
2 you can see that Y is going to equal
12 this and so what we've got here is
negative nine fifths comma 12 fifths is
the location of this reflective point
let's see if we're pretty accurate here
so this is like negative 1 in
four-fifths 12 this is like a 2 and 2/5
yea pretty accurate so that's the image
point when you reflect it over the line
so if you like the way that I explain
things you enjoy my videos you might be
interested in checking out my video
courses right down there I've got a link
to my algebra 1 video course algebra 2 a
CT math SAT math to help you in your
classes or with these specialized exams
I'll see you in those core
and I'll talk to you soon